let's talk about those floatels to start
with um
no no these we saw these uh actually the
Scottish government used them in Glasgow
for housing some Ukrainian refugees when
they came over as well so I think what
we want to do is try and get people into
a situation where we're not having to
use hundreds of hotels at really high
cost across the country and look at
better ways of managing our immigration
system so 500 or more people can come
and go as they like in this small area
no and some of them are going to be in
ports particularly ports are quite
protected areas so it's I think it's
about trying to manage these people as
well as possible while their immigration
statuses can they come and go as they
please or not well it's uh it's
obviously ports are protected areas so
there's so there's uh so they can get
off the boat but not out of the port
well that will be the same so certainly
the case in some of the areas such type
of prison then no it's not a type of
prison at all what these places are is
places for people to be safe and secure
while their immigration uh claims and
Asylum claims are processed in the UK
when they get off the boat they can't go
into the local Town well I think there's
a there that we try and we try and have
them we're trying I think we try and
have a situation and one of the issues
that a lot of people are worried about
is what are the um what impacts they'll
have on local Services that's right I I
understand that's why you're asking okay
um and one of the things that we're
going to ensure with all of these sites
is things like doctor's facilities they
will have on-site and so that they can
be processed there and looked after on
site without the need to impact on local
communities because I think that's the
issue that most people have is are my
local Services going to be affected by
this and actually what we're doing with
housing significant numbers in an
individual places in ensuring that
there's other services that will be
needed while these people go through the
Asylum processing system are provided as
far as possible on site but this is
going to happen every 28 days because
you're going to move people out every 28
days to Rwanda or wherever else they
might be going so there's going to be a
constant stream of people well what
we're hoping is that over time this will
provide that proper effective deterrence
to stop people illegally crossing the
channel but we've already seen a
decrease for example in the number of
um Albanian migrants crossing the
channel
what about what is going to happen every
28 days if it goes according to plan 200
odd people are going to go another 200
odd people are going to come if it goes
according to plan over time what we'll
see is a general fall and a reduction in
the number of people
well in the short term there will
obviously be people moving in and out of
them yeah but what we want to do and the
entire base this is to try and create an
effective system so we can a get these
cases dealt with really quickly and B
provide a deterrent for anybody trying
to bypass a normal immigration and
Asylum system by using uh Small Boat
Crossings what I want to see and why
constituents want to see is to see
people coming through the normal
channels we do have certain episodes of
course everybody does well that's not
happening at the moment 222 on this
barge what's going to happen to the
other 166 000. well there's as I said
how many boats are you going to need
well there's lots of options being
looked at the moment one is a lot of
votes one is around this used uh
military bases that's uh one place
that's being looked at at the moment I
know that the immigration Minister has
been looking at that the foreign
secretary said absolutely not in my
backyard well I think everybody has to
take their responsibility as ministers
including the foreign of course I've got
an immigration removal system Tim told
have you listening this morning which
started in my uh which has been set up
in my own constituency to help to remove
illegal migrants from the UK I think
we've all got to take our a share of
that but what I think we do want to see
is a something something uh using huge
quantities a very expensive hotel
accommodation is this going to be
cheaper because there are some
suggestions it's not so my understanding
is that's exactly the plan is that a
it's going to be cheaper B it provides
more of a deterrent and C it means that
you're not going to impact those local
communities as much because you're going
to have more of those facilities
provided on site
that we've seen the pictures in the
paper this morning they can play pool
they can go to the gym have a wild time
well I think what we want to see is that
done in a controlled environment as far
as possible and so that we can manage
those situations and manage those people
through the Asylum and immigration
process and when will that happen when
will the first people be on the barge
well I think that this is being looked
at at the moment I know contracts are
being discussed at the moment around the
UK with different areas so I can't give
you a definite date and timeline on it
before but this is what we're hoping to
do is what we're hoping to do as quickly
as possible in a month could even be
sooner than that it might be a little
bit further away but this is something
we're really Keen to get on top of it's
one of the top priorities for people is
to show that we've got control of our
own borders and we're also dealing with
this backlog um I want to see that done
as quickly as possible able but you know
we need to get these contracts in place
and it will be as you say there will be
a large number of them required across
the UK and there'll be different
solutions there but we can't have a
situation in which people are housed in
hotels in the center of towns across the
country what we also can't have it's
kids sitting on coaches for 20 hours at
the Port of Dover what are you doing to
make sure that doesn't happen this
weekend well look there's actually over
the last um you know decades there's
always been surgeries that um when
people are at a particular peak times
particularly bank holidays weekends I
don't think that's I don't think that's
true actually I think you have you did
see it
um years before when people are getting
away
um for a family holiday I think I'm
going to ask you about brexit I'm not
I'm asking you how are you going to make
sure that kids are not sitting on a
coach and have to be fed Pizza I I think
I think it was particularly important
the port of Dover issued some press
releases yesterday making clear that
their responsibility in dealing with
this situation I agree with them I think
the situation which has been there is
unacceptable I don't want to see uh kids
on coaches or families in cars queuing
up
um unless it's awaiting necessarily long
periods of time
um though you should be apologizing for
that well I think it's been it's over
made it very clear that there was a
difficult situation there that uh there
was some weather related issues in the
channel as well um but you know there's
and there's gonna and there's going to
be uh pinch points when they're at peak
times of the year and small things could
knock those um best laid plans off as
well Minister you will have seen
yesterday that there was a Quest this is
your brief an inquest heard how a crash
on a smart Motorway killed two
pensioners wouldn't have happened if
there had been a hard shoulder you're
pausing any small smart motorways going
forward
um it is time to stop them isn't it they
are dangerous well I think that's
exactly the reason we're pausing them is
to see overall what the impact is and we
need to get that data there what the
data shows to date is that um actually
there's separating uh traffic moving
into two different directions is the
safest thing that we can do and so our
Motorway Network and our Azure
carriageway network is very
significantly safe about three times as
safe as URI traveling on a normal a road
in the constituency like mine where
there isn't that formal separation of
traffic and where also you can get
there's nothing to do with smart
motorways smart motorways is when you
get rid of the hard shoulder well I
think there's a combination of things
because actually if you reduce shoulder
these pensions wanted to die if you
reduce capacity if you reduce capacity
on the motorway Network all you're doing
is you're automatically pushing Vehicles
onto other parts of the road Network as
well so there is it's not a it's not a
you know one size fits all on this I
think the key thing is the government's
accepted that there are issues here
which is why we've paused the scheme
we're also putting 900 million pounds in
to retrofit the smart Motorway Network
exactly tackling some of the issues
you've just raised such as those Refuge
areas uh we're putting those in right
across the entire smart Motorway Network
at the moment and that's why overall
we're having that proper pause to look
at what we can what more can be done
um but the the other side of the piece
here is that smart motorways are are
monitored which also helps you to pick
up problems earlier than you would do
without that monitoring across the
system would you be on the roads this
Easter I will and uh you know and and I
think we can all welcome today the
government's announcement of 47.5
million pounds for another see I didn't
think you were going to get to what
you've got there over 20 schemes right
across the country you know this is from
uh this is also some of our most
dangerous roads what we've recognize is
that yes driver behavior is a major
Factor but there's also other factors
such as design of Roads design of Road
Junctions adverse cameras on some parts
of the road Network what I want to do is
spend as much money as we can improving
road safety and some of that has got to
be in better driver training but some of
it also has to be on ensuring that our
roads are as safe as possible
particularly some of our smaller roads
which this fund are safely stop or
you'll get me in trouble all right